AT HOW THE MEDIA ARE COVERING IT
ALL UP.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS AT THE
END OF DAY 42, CAN YOU BELIEVE
IT, AMERICA IN SHUTDOWN.
NOW, MANY OF YOU ARE PROBABLY
FEELING KIND OF LIKE I’M
FEELING.
IT’S A WEIRD FEELING, ISN’T IT?
IT’S HORRIBLE -- IF YOU LIKE ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED OUT
THERE -- THEY’RE ALSO LIVING IN
KIND OF A TIME WARP, BECAUSE YOU
THINK BACK LIKE IN THE PRE-COVID
DAYS, SEEMS LIKE A LONG TIME AGO
IN A WAY, YOU COULD DO THINGS
LIKE DRIVE TO VISIT YOUR FRIENDS
OR MAYBE STOP IN TO SEE HER
PARENTS OR A RELATIVE.
YOU MIGHT HAVE DROPPED HER CHILD
OFF AT SCHOOL.
OR YOU COULD GO OUT ON A
SATURDAY NIGHT, MAYBE GO TO A
BALL GAME, MAYBE GO TO DINNER.
IN THE PRECOVID ROAD, YOU DIDN’T
HAVE TO WALK AROUND LIKE YOU’RE
PLAYING MEDICAL DRESS-UP.
YOU SHOOK HANDS WHEN YOU MET
SOMEONE OR MAKING A BET.
YOU HUGGED YOUR SON’S BEST
FRIEND WHEN HE MADE HONOR ROLL.
YOU SHOOK HANDS AND YOU MET
SOMEONE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IT’S WHAT YOU DID.
YOU WENT TO CHURCH.
MAYBE YOU EVEN PLANNED A FUN
SUMMER GETAWAY.
YOU ARE MAKING DECENT MONEY.
BUT SIX WEEKS AFTER MOST OF US
LOST A LOT OF THESE FREEDOMS,
THIS IS WHERE THINGS STAND IN
OUR MOST POPULOUS STATE.
FOLKS THERE SEEM TO HAVE HAD
ENOUGH OF THE LOCK DOWN.
TALK.
THEIR NUMBERS, WELL, THIS IS
WHERE THEY ARE.
THEY LOST 1776 OF THEIR CITIZENS
TO COVID.
IN A STATE OF 40 MILLION THAT’S
NEARLY 45 PEOPLE ARE MILLION.
COMPARED TO 1,145 PER MILLION IN
NEW YORK, THINK OF THAT
DIFFERENTIAL.
THAT’S REPORTED 22,500 DEATHS,
BY THE WAY, IN NEW YORK DESPITE
HAVING HALF THE POPULATION OF
THE GOLDEN STATE.
NOW, YOU TALK ABOUT DEATHS AND
IT GETS VERY STERILE LIKE IT
DOESN’T MEAN ANYTHING.
OF COURSE EVERY DEATH IS TRAGIC.
EVERY LIFE IS IRREPLACEABLE.
THAT GOES WITHOUT SAYING.
CALIFORNIA BY COMPARISON TO A
LOT OF OTHER STATES, ESPECIALLY
NEW JERSEY, NEW YORK, IS DOING
FAR BETTER WITH ABOUT ONE 20TH
OF THE COVID DEATHS OF THE
EMPIRE STATE.
AGAIN, PEOPLE ARE SEEING THIS.
THEY’RE NOT DUMB.
THE DATA DOESN’T LIE, THE DATA
IS WHAT THE DATA IS.
SO THIS IS WHAT THE BEACHES
LOOKED LIKE IN CALIFORNIA THIS
WEEKEND.
WELL, GOVERNOR NEWSOM WAS SOME
KIND OF UNHAPPY.
SPEAK WITH THE IMAGES SAW OVER
THE WEEKEND, THE IMAGES DOWN IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND VENTURA COUNTY
ON OUR BEACHES.
THOSE IMAGES ARE AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT NOT TO SEE.
PEOPLE, WHAT NOT TO DO.
IF WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS THAT WE’VE
MADE IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
EXTEND INTO THE NEXT NUMBER OF
WEEKS.
>> Laura: IT YOU’RE GETTING
THE SENSE THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE JUST STARTING TO TUNE HIM
AND A LOT OF OTHER BLUE STATE
POLITICIANS OUT AS WELL.
WELL, THERE WERE PROTESTS IN
LAS VEGAS, A MASSIVE CARAVAN OF
PEOPLE SHOWED UP ON THE STRIP
THERE AND WITH THE SUNSHINE,
CABIN FEVER HITTING, MORE AND
MORE AMERICANS JUST WANT TO GET
ON WITH THEIR LIVES.
THEY WANT TO DO IT SAFELY BUT
THEY HAVE TO GET ON WITH THEIR
LIVES.
OF COURSE THE MEDIA, THEY ARE
THERE LYING IN WAIT.
YOU GET THE SENSE THAT SOME
MIGHT BE GHOULISHLY WATCHING TO
SEE IF STATES LIKE GEORGIA --
REMEMBER, GEORGIA OPEN FIRST.
WHETHER THEY SHOW A MAJOR UPTICK
IN HOSPITALIZATIONS DUE TO
COVID.
BUT AS ONE GEORGIA BARBERSHOP
OWNER TOLD US ON FRIDAY, IT’S A
MATTER OF HIS SURVIVAL AS WELL.
>> I HAD NO INCOME FOR THE LAST
TWO MONTHS.
I OWN THREE BARBERSHOPS, ALSO
CUT HERE MYSELF.
AND US BEING OUT OF WORK,
THERE’S NO MONEY COMING IN AT
ALL.
SO MY QUESTION TO THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE, WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
SHOULD WE JUST LET -- YOU KNOW,
JUST SIT BACK AND WAIT FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO BAIL US OUT?
OR TAKE ADVANTAGE OF AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE AND BE
AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE AND STILL,
YOU KNOW, MAKE AS MUCH MONEY AS
WE CAN AND YOU KNOW, JUST PLAY
IT SAFE?
>> Laura: MEANWHILE, REMEMBER
PRECOVID WHEN THIS WAS A STORY?
SPEAK OF THE FLU IS ALREADY
WIDESPREAD IN FIVE STATES AND
LAST YEAR AT THIS POINT IT
WASN’T WIDESPREAD ANYWHERE.
>> THE NUMBER OF FLU CASES THAT
WE’RE DETECTING IS MUCH HIGHER
THAN WE WOULD EXPECT TO SEE AT
THIS POINT IN TIME IN ANY
AVERAGE YEAR.
THEY GO YOU SEE ALL THAT RED?
HOW COULD YOU NOT?
THAT SHOULD BE A RED FLAG ABOUT
JUST HOW BAD THIS YEAR’S FLU
SEASON HAS GOTTEN.
>> Laura: BACK IN EARLY
JANUARY BEFORE HE BECAME A
GLOBAL SUPERSTAR, DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI TOLD CNN THAT THIS FLU
SEASON WAS ON TRACK TO BE AS
SEVERE AS THE 2017-2018 SEASON,
WHICH WAS THE DEADLIEST IN MORE
THAN FOUR DECADES.
HE SAID THE INITIAL INDICATORS
INDICATE IT’S NOT GOING TO BE A
GOOD SEASON.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A BAD
SEASON.
BUT AFTER THOSE INITIAL
WARNINGS, THE STORY SEEMED TO
KIND OF GO AWAY.
THIS DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE
KNOW THAT AT LEAST 169 CHILDREN
HAVE DIED THIS FLU SEASON.
THAT’S ONLY SECOND TO THE 188
DIED DURING THE 2017-2018
SEASON.
AT LEAST THREE CHILDREN HAVE
DIED DUE TO COVID.
LOOK AT THESE GRAPHS FROM
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
SOME OF THE MATH THERE.
WEEK AFTER WEEK, THE MORTALITY
NUMBERS IN THE INFLUENZA --
PNEUMONIA, WERE CLIMBING.
DESPITE ALL THIS THOUGH,
CIVILIZATION DIDN’T GRIND TO A
HALT.
SCHOOLS DIDN’T CLOSE, WE DIDN’T
EVEN TALK ABOUT IT.
H1N1, THE SWINE FLU, WAS
PARTICULARLY VICIOUS THIS YEAR,
WHEREAS THE BEAST RAIN HIT THE
YOUNG HARDEST.
LOOK AT THIS GRAPH OF JUST HOW
BAD THE FLU SEASON WAS.
LOOK AT WHERE IT WENT UP.
YOU CAN SEE IN THE GRAPH, THAT
READ AS IT GOES UP AND IT GOES
UP TOWARDS THE END OF WEEK 16,
WHICH IS IN APRIL, BUT IT
ACTUALLY WENT UP TO EPIDEMIC
LEVELS, A LITTLE BIT OVER THAT
WHITE LINE, BEFORE YOU WOULD
IMAGINE THOSE COVID DEATHS WERE
ACTUALLY COUNTED.
IT WAS A NASTY SEASON, SO IT
QUALIFIED AS A NATIONAL EPIDEMIC
WEEK AFTER WEEK OR CLOSE TO IT.
NOW, COVID IS NOT THE FLU, WE
ARE NOT SAYING THAT.
IT’S A LOT MORE CONTAGIOUS AND
IT’S NEW.
IT HITS THE OLD HARDEST, YOUNG,
RELATIVELY UNSCATHED BY IT,
RELATIVELY.
AND ACCORDING TO RESEARCHERS,
THERE ARE AS MANY AS 33
MUTATIONS TO COVID-19.
YET THE COVID MORTALITY RATE WE
NOW KNOW BECAUSE WE NOW HAVE THE
DATA IS A FRACTION OF WHAT A LOT
OF THE PROFESSIONALS, THE
EXPERTS, TOLD US IT WOULD BE.
WELL, AS INCONVENIENT TRUTHS
LIKE THAT THAT LED DOCTORS
ERICKSON -- WHO JOIN US IN
MOMENTS, TO PRODUCE A VIDEO
CALLING FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE
REOPENED.
>> 0.03 CHANCE OF DYING FROM
COVID IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IS THAT -- DOES THAT NECESSITATE
SHELTERING IN PLACE?
DOES THAT NECESSITATE SHUTTING
DOWN MEDICAL SYSTEMS?
DOES THAT NECESSITATE PEOPLE
BEING OUT OF WORK?
WHEN YOUR LITTLE CHILD CRAWLING
ON THE GROUND, PUTTING SOMETHING
IN HER MOUTH, VIRUSES AND
BACTERIA COME IN, FORM A
COMPLEX -- THIS IS HOW YOUR
IMMUNE SYSTEM IS BUILT.
YOU DON’T TAKE A SMALL CHILD,
PUT THEM IN BUBBLE WRAP IN A
ROOM AND SAY GO HAVE A HEALTHY
IMMUNE SYSTEM.
>> Laura: THEY ALSO SAY
THEY’RE HEARING FROM DOCTORS
DISCUSSING THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THERE IS A CONFLUENCE OF DEATHS
BEING REPORTED.
>> WHEN SOMEONE DIES IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW, THEY’RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE, DIABETES, THE STROKE.
THEY’RE SAYING THAT DID THEY
DIE -- WE’VE BEEN TO HUNDREDS OF
AUTOPSIES.
YOU DON’T TALK ABOUT ONE THING,
YOU TALK ABOUT COMORBIDITIES.
E.R. DOCTORS NOW, MY FRIENDS I
TALKED TO SAY, YOU KNOW, IT’S
INTERESTING WHEN I’M WRITING
ABOUT MY DEATH REPORT, I’M BEING
PRESSURED TO ADD COVID.
WHY IS THAT?
>> Laura: AND THEN THEY CAME
TO THIS CONCLUSION.
>> SOMETHING ELSE IS GOING ON
HERE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT SCIENCE AND
IT’S NOT EVEN ABOUT COVID.
WHEN THEY USE THE WORD SAFE, THE
WORD SAFE, IF YOU LISTEN TO THE
WORD SAFE, THAT’S ABOUT
CONTROLLING YOU.
>> Laura: WELL, BIG SCIENCE,
THE MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENT,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT IS
ALREADY COMING AFTER THEM SINCE
THEIR VIDEOS HAVE GONE, SORRY
FOR THE POND, VIRAL.